foreign
welcome back so we've talked about a
fourth stepwise selection backwards
stepways in all subsets as well as some
techniques for choosing the model size
all those methods fit by least squares
so whenever we consider model a subset
we always fit the coefficients by least
squares now we're going to talk about a
different a different method called
shrinkage
namely two techniques Ridge regression
and lasso
and as we'll see that these methods do
not use fully squares to fit but rather
different Criterion that has a penalty
that will shrink the coefficients
towards typically zero and we'll see
this can be these methods are very
powerful in particular they can be
applied to very large data sets like the
kind that we see more and more often
these days where the number of variables
might be in the thousands or even
Millions
so
um and one thing that's worth mentioning
is that like Ridge regression lasso and
shrinkage messages like this are a
really contemporary area of research
right now I mean there's papers every
day written by statisticians about
variants of these methods and how to
improve them and that sort of thing as
opposed to some of the other things that
we've covered so far in this course
where you know the ideas have been
around for 30 40 years although actually
for Ridge regression I think was evented
in the 70s but it's it is true that it
wasn't very popular for many many years
it's only sort of what the the Advent of
fast computation in the last 10 years
that it's become very very popular along
with the lasso so
um some of these methods are old some
are new but they're really quite hot now
in their applications
so Ridge regression now let's first of
all just remind ourselves what least
squares is the training error
um
so the RSS or training error is the sum
of squares deviation between Y and the
predictions
so when you do these squares we simply
find the coefficients that make this as
small as possible
now
with the rich regression we're going to
do something a little bit different
we're going to use training error RSS
we're going to we're going to add a
penalty to that namely
a tuning parameter which will choose in
some way and you'll as you can guess
it'll be back cross validation times the
sum of the squares of the coefficients
so this we're going to try to make this
total quantity small which means we're
going to try to make the the fit good by
making the RSS small but at the same
time we're going to have something which
is going to push us the other direction
this is going to penalize the
coefficients which get too large right
the bigger the the more non-zero
coefficient is the larger this is so
we're going to pay a price for being
non-zero it'll pay a a bigger price that
the larger the coefficients are
so it's it's basically Fit versus the
size of the coefficients
and that penalty is called a shrinkage
a shrinkage penalty because it's going
to encourage the the parameters to be to
be shrunk towards zero and the amount by
which you're encouraged to be zero is is
it will be uh determined by this this
tuning parameter Lambda
if Lambda is zero let's go back to this
if lambda zero of course we're just
doing least squares right because this
term will be zero but the larger Lambda
is
this tuning parameter the more and more
of a price will pay for making these
coefficients non-zero if you make Lambda
extremely large then at some point the
coefficients are going to be very close
to zero because they'll have to be close
to zero to make this this term small
enough right no matter how good they
help to fit we're going to pay a large
price in in
um
in the penalty term
so in other words This this term has the
effect of shrinking the coefficients
towards zero and Y zero while zero is a
natural value remember zero of course if
a coefficient is zero the feature is not
appearing in the model
so it's if you're going to shrink
towards some value that a zero is a is a
is a natural place to shrink towards
and the tuning parameter
the side swing parameter it trades off
the Fit versus the size of the
coefficients so as you can imagine the
choosing a good value for Lambda for for
extreme Prime Lambda is is critical and
cross validation is what we're going to
use for this
so let's see
what happens for the credit data
um well let me just go back here so
if we think of this for a fixed value of
Lambda we have to we have to find the
smallest value of this Criterion and
again it's just an optimization problem
with actually a very simple solution
and there are computer programs for
doing that so I've used such a program
and we'll talk in the actually in the r
session about
an R function for doing Ridge regression
but let's see what it looks like in this
example in the credit example so here
we've plotted the coefficients
um standardized coefficients versus
Lambda
for the credit data and let's see what
happens well first of all on the on the
left hand side
Lambda is close to zero so there's
almost no no constraint on the
coefficients so here we're pretty much
getting the full least squares estimates
and now as Lambda gets larger it's
pushing the coefficients towards zero
because we're paying more and more of a
price for being non-zero
in the extreme over here where Lambda is
a little more than are maybe more than
ten thousand the little coefficients are
all essentially zero
in between they're shrunken towards zero
as Lambda gets larger although not not
uh uniformly so right like this the
rating variable
actually gets bigger for a while and
then shrinks back down to zero
and I remember when I was a student
figure again and again actually was in a
class that Rob was teaching and being
totally confused
and Futures so I just want to spare
everyone this confusion in case anyone
shares a confusion I had so like if we
look here this red line indicates the
spot at which Lambda equals 100 and at
that spot the income coefficient takes
on a value of like negative 100
these other six coefficients here are
all around zero student takes on a value
of around 100
limited rating take on values of around
250 and so the point is what we're
plotting here is a ton of different
models for a huge grid of Lambda values
and you just need to choose the value of
Lambda and then look at that vertical
cross section
good and is so as Danielle said if we
chose the value of Lambda about was that
a hundred then it would seems like it
chooses about three non-zero
coefficients the black the blue and the
red oh maybe four and then these guys
here are basically essentially zero the
gray ones so they're not quite zero but
they're small right exactly so an
equivalent picture on the right now
we've plotted the um
the standardized coefficients as a
function of the of the the L2 Norm the
sums of the squares the square root of
the sum of the squares of the
coefficients divided by that the L2 Norm
of the fully squares coefficient so Rob
what's the L2 Norm okay
um
the L2 Norm so the L2 Norm of the beta
of the vector beta 1 through beta p
it's written this way or the
so the L2 Norm so it's the square root
of the sum
beta J squared
all right so this is the
that's the L2 norm and so it's synthesis
that's it so
um
we see here when the L2 Norm is zero so
when the coefficients are all zero the
L2 Norm is zero that corresponds to the
the the right side of this picture so
the Lambda is very large here it's large
enough that it's driven the L2 normal
down almost to zero so the coefficients
are basically zero
and then on the on the right
um Lambda is very small
and we get the full least squares
estimates
and in between we get again a shrunken
coefficient so these two pictures are
very the same but they've been flipped
from left to right
and the the x-axis are parameterized in
a different way so Rob why does um this
x-axis on the right hand side go from
zero to one why does it end at one oh
because we just we plotted the stat it
ends at one because we're plotting as a
function of this standardized L2 Norm so
at the right hand side
um
we get we have the basically the full
lead squares estimates so these
numerator and denominator are the same
right so on the right hand side here on
this right hand plot Lambda is zero and
so your Ridge regression estimate is the
same as your least squares estimate and
so that ratio is just one
exactly okay
um I think we've actually just said all
this
thanks for the questions from Daniella
um
right so there's the L2 Norm defined I
wrote it in the previous slide and
that's what was used for the plotting
axis
um one important point with Ridge
regression is that it it matters whether
you scale the variables or not now just
just to remind you if you just do
standardly squares so starting these
squares is called scale and variant If I
multiply a feature by a constant it's
not going to matter because I can divide
the coefficient by the same constant I
get the same answer so
in least squares the the scaling of the
of the variable that doesn't matter so
whether I measure a length in feet or
inches it's not going to matter because
the coefficient can just account for the
change in units
but it's a little bit subtle here now
for for Ridge regression and penalized
methods like rage regression the scaling
does matter in an important way
and that's because if we go back to the
definition of ridge regression
right
these coefficients are all put in a
penalty together and they're this
there's a sum of squares so if I change
the units of one variable it's going to
change the scale of the coefficients
well
if I change the units of one variable
the coefficient has to change to try to
accommodate for that change but it's
competing against the the coefficients
for other features so because they're
all put together in a penalty in a sum
the the uh the scale of the features
matters
and as a result
it's important to standardize the
predictors in regression before applying
Ridge regression so in most cases
before you do a ridge regression you
want to standardize the variables what
does that mean to standardize the
variables well you take the
the variable or feature and you divide
it by the standard deviation of that
feature over all the observations
and now the standard deviation of this
guy is one
and you do that for each feature and
that makes the features comparable and
makes their coefficients comparable
so that's an example of Ridge regression
compared to least squares here's a
simulated example with 50 observations
and 45 predictors in which all of the
predictors have been given non-zero
coefficients
so we see on the on the left we see the
um the bias in Black the variance in
green and the test air in purple for
Rich regression as a function of Lambda
and the same thing on the right as a
function now of the standardized
coefficients of the sorry of the of the
two Norm
of of the average regression divided by
the two over fully squares so again
these are the same pictures essentially
but the the x-axis have been changed
let's look over here we can see that
um
what happens while the
the bias as we move so fully squares is
is over here on the Left Right Lambda is
close to zero as we as we make Lambda
larger the bias is pretty much unchanged
but the variance drops
so so Ridge regression by shrinking the
coefficient towards zero controls the
variance it doesn't allow the
coefficient to be too big
and it gets rewarded because the mean
square error which is the sum of these
two goes down
so here's the here's the place where the
mean square is minimized and it's lower
than that for than the fully squared
estimate so in this example Ridge
regression has improved the error the
the mean square error of
fully squares by shrinking the
coefficients
by a certain amount and we see the same
thing on in this picture and actually
this U-shaped curve that we see for the
um the mean squared error in this figure
in purple comes up again and again where
when we're considering a bunch of
different models that sort of have
different levels of flexibility or
complexity there's usually some sweet
spot in the middle that has the smallest
test error and that's really what we're
going for so that's what's marked as an
X in these two figures
so I want to go back to this picture of
Ridge let me clear the
and one thing you might have noticed
here that we mentioned is that the
coefficients are never exactly zero
they're close to zero like here these
gray guys are all closer but they're
they're never exactly zero matter of
fact you can show mathematically that
they're unless you're extremely lucky
you're not gonna get a coefficient
exactly of zero so Ridge regression
shrinks things in a continuous way
towards zero but doesn't actually select
variables by setting a coefficient equal
to zero exactly but it seems like a Pity
in this example right because all those
gray variables are so tiny it would just
be more convenient if they were zero
right which is a great setup for the
next method
called the lasso